[Music]
awesome thank you all for coming out
of course Liz was just on stage talking
about JavaScript Colombia and this is an
amazing conference for any of you that
haven't made it out to Medellin to
JavaScript Colombia it is amazing the
city's wonderful this they take care of
the speakers great so please please get
your talks into them all right well
thank you to coming to our talk teaching
kids to code by a 13 year old and most
of you could probably guess I'm not 13
so I'd like to introduce my son Michael
hello everyone my name is Michael I am a
13 year old boy and I enjoy all things
Pokemon Lego Star Wars now playing video
games and VR all day if you let me he
will and my name is Jason on his dad I'm
the CEO of a company called code up back
in the States and we teach adults how to
code I love Star Wars and Legos as well
I know a little bit about Pokemon and
video games are alright so what we'd
like to do before we talk about teaching
kids to code and giving you some tools
to go back home and teach some kids to
code we want to talk about why why
should kids learn how to code and I
think most of the people in this
audience have some opinions about that
but I wanted to find out from a kid so
Michael why do you think kids should
code well kids need a better
understanding of technology mostly kids
I know think technology is Google
YouTube and for tonight and that's not
even close to the possibilities encoding
sparks imagination coding makes you
really creative it makes you want to do
amazing stuff it's a great way to teach
children logic like if something happens
to do something else you can also learn
how things work you can learn how you
can email or you can learn how computers
work it's cooler programs things like
it's cool to build Legos it's cool play
games it is cool and awesome to program
things it's also really fun I do it on a
daily basis awesome
so before we get into the right way to
teach kids how to code we figured we'd
go over a few of the things that we
think are the wrong way to do it and
last summer Michael was super excited to
go to a camp where they were going to
teach minecraft mods' using Java and I
think we learned a few things that
probably are the things you want to
avoid when trying to teach a kid to code
well the first thing is to start with a
hard language like Java or C during that
camp
I used rava and it was not fun I don't
know how it works to date oh I knows
like C I don't don't ask me and making
them learn to type well it's I still use
my pointer fingers kids still use two
foreign fingers most people I know use
foreign from yours and using complicated
tools like eclipse when we are doing the
mods we use Eclipse I have no idea how
to go back to my previous projects I
have no idea that how that even works
unfortunately learned vocabulary like
Clinton couldn't cut couldn't pick that
make sure there you go wow I've no idea
what that means
Dean that they really need to learn math
verbs like algebra calculus terrible way
to start so what we found is if you
wanted to teach a kid a musical
instrument
you would probably teach him a song
before you made them learn music theory
or how to read music and what I found is
apparent it's once Michael was out
creating video games all of the things
on this slide he became more interested
in but if this is where we start that
it's really hard to get them excited
about writing code so that being said we
want to think about what is it the kids
want to do and this picture definitely
shows what I want to do all day every
all day long if I let him but Michael
what do you think the kids want to do
when they're learning how to code well
they want to see media results if they
press WR up from the game they're
playing they don't want to wait ten
seconds to play wait you're telling me
kids aren't patient I've been waiting
for you to say that and they like to
create things that are fun like games or
Legos we're gonna go back to Legos a lot
but they like to create things that
they're interested in and sharing their
creations again back to Legos
they love to show it after they build a
set even I do I could show it to my
parents showing what I am capable of and
to make new graphics like doing artwork
or fanart or anything like that they
love to do that and building things that
they love once again Legos they love
that last but not least they like to
play with the results guess what
Legos they love to play with Legos
before they pong the shelf and let it
dust and oh sorry
awesome so we've talked a little bit
about the wrong way and why kids want to
do it what kids are into so we'd like to
present what we think is a great
solution for teaching kids to code and
in this put solution that we want to
show you Michael do you have to learn
how to type no it is strike and drop and
it was super hard to learn right took
weeks no it was easy learned and I
learned how to make a game one in the
first day and let me guess you're only a
few of you online that are doing a
ginormous humongous community of users
and when I say hey Michael why don't you
go write a piece of software you think
that you're being punished right no it's
fun to use almost as close video games
where you found that anybody was able to
help you
yes everyone who helped it's pretty easy
learned but if you do need help anyone
can help but what about creating games
did you have to download a bunch of
special stuff
no ok one in the first hour of playing
without downloading what if you wanted
to have your own graphics in there
graphic designs are included and awesome
so what we'd like to do is show you the
solution that's worked for us and that
scratch by MIT it's super cool so
Michael why don't you tell us what is
scratch so scratch is a programming
language developed by MIT in 2003 it's
for age it's even up I start around
seminary and right now it has over 22
million users and roughly around 25,000
new members join every day Wow
and just what it's in German it's in
Spanish it's in Japanese
there's over 70 languages it uses and it
only requires internet access and
because of the recent 3.0 update no
flash
thank you John for saving us awesome so
to get scratch it's super simple you
just point your browser to
scratch.mit.edu
and click create and you're presented
with an IDE that looks just like this
and Michael can walk
through the different aspects so as you
can see in the top right corner there is
the stage that's where everything's
going to happen that's where we render
it sprites are gonna be moving and
changing sprites are the objects on the
stage that as I said they're gonna
change move let's do something
Rex is out of the backdrops those are
the stages of the stage play on what's
there and it changes it can dry other
code all that in the middle there is the
coding area that's where you're gonna be
putting your code to make either the
sprites backdrops or stage change next
to that are the blocks those are the
chunks of code they'd be sticking
together and making your thing work
above that are the tabs pretty simple
code I just showed you what that was
costumes is where either sprites your
backdrops can change and will just
interest them and sounds and it
describes itself with just make sounds
or music all you where to download our
slides
this is explaining kind of an
explanation alright so what we'd like to
do is a typical hello world using
scratch so Michaels gonna come over do a
little bit of live coding for you here
today in Berlin and scratch cat is the
sprite that is default it's gonna be
what loads on the page this is what you
get when you load up the page and how
about you show us a hello world script
Michael so first we're gonna go to
events and grab the wind flag is clicked
lock you're gonna need this for every
piece of code you do then we go to looks
let's grab a say hello just make that a
simple hello world still use my pointer
fingers and go over to motion we have
ten steps just make that 50 so you guys
can see that
alright let's blow it up and hit play
yeah they go there we go
so within just a couple of minutes that
kid that you're trying to teach how to
code can have their hello world script
writing not having to learn how to type
not having to know all of those things
that kind of get in the way so the next
what we'd like to do is create a game
for you live right here and Mike already
went to the background and use the
graphic that editing tools created all
of his own graph
and what we see there is Jeff standing
at an airport in some lederhosen holding
a beer why don't you tell us the premise
of the game Michael so Jeff is the
German dude I'm not gonna do anything
weird he's there and he's gonna be
throwing beer in schnitzel ah angry
glasses bearded dads who are coming off
of 48-hour airplanes with only three
hours of sleep and he's gonna be super
angry and he's gonna and Jeff is gonna
throw beers and throw schnitzels to make
him happy so angry dads are gonna come
off the airplanes and they want beer and
angry here did bathmats where did you
get this idea with grey beards ah ok
well let's check it out so the first
thing that we want to do is be able to
make Jeff our main character move around
so Michael why don't you show us how we
can make Jeff move left when you hit the
left arrow button so first of course we
have to go to offense and grab the wind
flag is clicked block again you always
gonna need this go to control and grab a
forever and an F so that's we're ever
gonna be asking the question if
something happens didn't do whatever's
in the loop the thing we're gonna be
asking is gonna be a few space press but
it's not gonna be space it's going to be
left arrow we're gonna go to motion
we're going to point in direction left
which is negative 90 and then move 10
steps alright so we hit the flag we hit
the left arrow button oh wait that is
something wrong
do we have internet do we have internet
okay
let's go it on here oh I've on wrong
sprite oh we clicked on the wrong sprite
very good catch thank you
why coding is always fun all right so
let's try that again on the Jeff sprite
as you can tell every sprites its own
object so we had it in the wrong piece
of code now Jeff moves left alright good
job thank you thank you very much all
right so now we got Jeff moving left but
I think he needs to move right as well
so how do we go in there and make you
move right easy you right click and
duplicate something amazing about
scratch so we go here and go right arrow
and make that right perfect soom and so
we got moonwalking Jeff yeah Michael
Jefferson I guess alright why don't we
make it or what he's moving the other
direction he's pointing in the direction
that he's supposed to be moving so
before we do that I'd like to show the
costumes as you see I have a right and a
left costume these are gonna be very
important to make it move so we go back
to code
he looks start out that we go down here
and go to switch costume to right and
put that bit there as well but this left
right so that when he moves left and
right he'll be paid facing that
direction but Jeff can't move up and
down how hard would it be to add that
I'm not very it's just and right click
ok so we're gonna duplicate two more if
statements so we're gonna have 4 nested
if statements in there checking to see
if it's going up down left or right
Michael's gonna get all of those set up
we're gonna remove that switch costume
for the up and down because we don't
have an up-and-down costume just set the
directions to down and up and when we
click play we should have a fully moving
Jeff moves everywhere even diagonal
check that out so in just a few minutes
you're able to get the basics of a 2d
game going but right now it's just Jeff
running around on a stage how about we
bring in one of those airplanes and see
if we can't get some of those angry dads
to come off
airplane Michael coming in for landing
all right so that we have another sprite
this is the airplane sprite it's gonna
be like its own object and what Michael
is gonna do is start having Angry dads
come off of the plane and go chase down
Jeff trying to get that beer and
schnitzel
so of course go over to events and grab
the wind flag is clicked go to control
and do forever wait one second and
create fun of myself so it's gonna wait
one second and then creates one of
myself but one point bit too sure why
don't we uh why don't we make that a
little more random just go to operators
pick random one two ten big span let's
just make it two to six Bigham so now
every two to six seconds this sprite is
going to create a clone of itself
and now Michaels going to show you what
we can do with that clone so you rather
when I start to clone then you're also
gonna grab a repeat until good emotion
you're going to point towards a Jeff and
move ten steps to go all right so let's
see what happens here and we wait two to
six seconds randomly and alright so how
could we fix that so instead of
airplanes coming out of airplanes we
have angry dads so first I like to
costumes there's planing there's chase
and he looks a little familiar I didn't
do that
yeah all right so let's find a way to
get him off the plane they go back to
code go to let's just switch costing the
plane accepts nothing you plane so now
every time a clone created it should be
an angry dad we hit play Jeff's gonna
run around and here they got angry dad's
coming off of the air berry chasing down
Jeff I have never run that fast in my
life you can't convince me that was
based on me okay let me just make it six
okay fine well make it slower but here's
the problem when they're catching Jeff
they're drinking his beer and taking a
schnitzel shouldn't they disappear I
mean
you want and sure why don't we show how
we could do that okay fine so go over to
sensing and do touching mouse pointer
change that to touching Jeff so now we
have a repeat until lamp a lot like a
do-while um go to control again delete
this clone so once that loop completes
the clone will be deleted yep so now
let's go back in alright so Jeff's out
running around the airport every two to
six seconds there comes Ingrid adds off
the plane and when they click Jeff they
go away but wouldn't it be great if we
could get them some beer and schnitzel
before they caught Jeff indeed let's go
to food and drink of I was like selling
this tablet look we have a beer we
understand it soul I like the beer
better than possible so when we click on
this third sprite now we see that
there's no code there for that object
we're gonna say whenever the game starts
so when flag is clicked whenever the
game starts we're going to go to control
forever yes and also grab while we're
here a create clone myself put that
inside then we go sensing we grab key
space press we're gonna keep it that go
back to control I should have grabbed
this was here so again we're creating a
clone every time the spacebar key is
pressed and then we're gonna go to reign
in position no we're gonna go to Jeff
and then we're also look at this I
should've grabbed so much stuff while I
was here to repeat until and then we're
going to have the motion moves ten steps
then they go okay so now every time he
hits the spacebar clone should be made
of the food object and then it should
start moving ten steps from where it
originates at Jeff it's still hittin oh
just like CSS I have show and hide for
your sprites so now we need to show they
go perfect awesome wait but that's like
an endless supply of schnitzel and
they're sticking to the end why don't we
make it where you have to let go of the
spacebar in between but I want you on
cat I can see that well why don't we see
what we can do by cleaning that up
just a little bit all right oh there
comes the angry Jason's hmm so we
haven't where right now what should we
fix this machine gun or let's make it to
where you don't have a machine gun
schnitzel okay so we go over to control
wait until with an operator's grab a not
duplicate this so now it's going to
repeat and saying if the key space is
pressed Nick clone you cannot repeat
until the key space pressed is not being
pressed so you gotta let go of the
spacebar between every time let's see
how that's working oh yeah
oh I'm holding it I'm perfect BAM
alright but they are sticking to the
edge of the screen there so we should
probably make them disappear when they
click when they get to the edge of the
stage so we make it we're touching the
edge we're going to make it waiter
deletes a clone so when it falls out of
the repeat loop the while loop then they
won't stick to the sides that's perfect
but what I notice is when the angry dads
are coming off the airplane and you try
to give them a schnitzel they keep
coming so we should probably make that
angry dad disappear as soon as he gets
that beer schnitzel so let's go back to
plane one we're gonna go two operators
grab an oar duplicate yes and meaning so
it's gonna repeat until it's either
touching the food and drink sprite or
the Jeff sprite and then they should
disappear and we should have angry dad's
coming off getting ready to get that
good German beer and schnitzel and there
it is able to feed them and make them
happy but it's only signal coming out
you have the games a little easy right
now you can just stand in front of the
plane and spam angry dads what if we
have a second plane easy so you so so
you can not just copy code you can also
duplicate sprites oh and if you notice
what he duplicated the sprite all the
code duplicated or swell so now when we
hit play we have a video game that's
twice as hard and twice as fun it's got
something
interplaying Michael coming in for Lane
oh there we go alright so we're feeding
schnitzels to angry dad's coming off of
airplanes delete their location it's
only shooting schnitzels to the left how
do we make it to where they can shoot
missiles both ways all right we're gonna
go to variables if you don't know that
variables are I think you might be at
the wrong talk so let's make a variable
and call it dir F or not all caps again
D I are digging out for direction so
it's gonna be our direction variable one
of the things that you should know is
variables in scratch or global so any
variable you create and any sprite can
be accessed from any other sprite
Michael's now gonna set those variables
to whatever Jeff's pointing left or
right so I have it where it's either
negative ninety or ninety miles if it's
right or left you could also see for
debugging that the variables visible on
the stage but you can just uncheck it if
you don't want it to be there so real
quick drag eight Derr Derr
sorry that you so we're back on the food
and wine food and drink sprite so
pointing direction der go out using that
variable and whichever way Jeff is
pointed that's the way the schnitzels
are coming but I noticed there's only
schnitzels I thought we said beer in
schnitzels I can fix that so much that
they go so now we go into Lux and do
switch costume to beer and to the beer
we're gonna go into uh operators and
switch it's pick random one two two so
if you look in the costumes it's
numbered one and two full so if I did
this so now he's randomly shooting beer
and schnitzels angry dads are coming off
of the airplane they want to get that
beer from Jeff but he's able to deliver
one for them before they get to him and
we have the basics of a 2d video game in
about 15 minutes
written by a thirteen-year-old this is
something you can all go home and do
thank you
now if you give you about 30 or 45
minutes he can build a completely
fleshed out video game and that's what
we'd like to show you right now it's the
final version of angry dad and Jeff if
you notice in the bottom right hand
corner we have a beer mug that's gonna
be the life of Jeff and let's watch him
play around so it's the same game that
you saw except this time when angry
dad's come off and they actually come
and drink Jeff's beer from him he starts
running out and so we can see that when
they do catch him his life meter goes
down there's but go ahead
there's the keg which also refills your
beer meter but when he gets the keg it
refills his beer so as long as these
shooting beards and other people they're
staying happy but when they get to you
know it's gonna have they drink all of
his mayor and game over there's a bugger
on Andy fix it hey what's wrong
it didn't go to end screen that's fine
so thank you all for coming out and
seeing this we if you want to flip it
back there our contact information
there's the game over screen that's what
we were looking for thank you you want
to go to our final stream laughs awesome
we'd love it if you run it to reach out
and get in touch with us my name is
Jason straw and you can contact me on
Twitter at JD strong or at Jason at code
up calm I am Michael strong you can
contact me a masterbuilder michael at
gmail.com and thank you all for come to
our talk
good job yeah
[Music]